we're asked to compute 3060 divided by
36 so we want to figure out how many
times does 36 I'll write it let me I
don't need to write that vague we need
to figure out how many times does 36 go
into 36 go into 3060 3060 now this is
interesting because we're dividing by a
two-digit number by 36 we're going to
see in this video that the process is
the exact same way there's just going to
be a little bit more of mental
estimation going on but we'll do it
explicitly here so hopefully it won't be
too bad so we first look at 36 we say
well does 36 go into 3 well no 3 is
smaller than 36 so it won't go into 3
does 36 go into 30 no 30 is still
smaller than 36 so it won't go into that
does 36 go into 306 well sure
306 is larger than 36 and if we were to
estimate it let's see 30 would go into
300 10 times but this is larger than 30
so it's going to go a few up it's going
to go fewer times maybe it's 9 I'm not
sure let's try it out let me try it out
over the side what is 36 times 9 36
times 9 and this is kind of the art of
doing these problems when you're
dividing a two-digit number into
something so 6 times 9 is 54 6 times 9
is 54 regroup or carry the 5 3 times 9
is 27 plus 5 27 plus 5 is 32 so 36 times
9 is 324 that's still larger than 306 so
it's going to be we're gonna have to go
36 less than that so we have to do 8
times so we're going to have to go into
it 8 times and the way remember the way
I thought about that is well I said my
first guess is maybe it goes in 9 times
but when I tried out 36 times nine that
was still larger than 306 that got me
324 eight times should work because if
you take 36 away if you only do 8 times
36 that's going to take us below 300 320
for 136 away from that or another
3300 24-36 is going to get us below 300
so let's try this out and just make sure
8 times 6 8 times 6 is 48 put the 8
there carry the 4 8 times 3 is 24 plus 4
is 28 so 8 times 36 is 288 and it fits
it's less than 306 9 would have been too
much it would've been greater than 306
so now we can just subtract now we can
just subtract so we have 6 minus 8 we
can't just subtract 8 from 6 we have to
do a little bit of regrouping let's get
a 10 from the ones place right here but
we can't borrow anything from here or
regroup anything from there so let's go
to the hundreds place let's get let's
take one from the hundreds place and so
this will become a 2 and then this 0
here will become a 10 well another way
to think about it is this is now 10
hundreds or I'm sorry this is now 10
tens we took 100 from there and we're
not we're not writing 100 as 10 tens or
another way to think about it is you
borrow 2 1 or you took a 1 really
you took a 1 from the hundreds place
that made it into a 2 and then you put
the 1 out in front of the 0 that's kind
of the process way of thinking about it
now we have this 10 here and now we can
borrow from this 10 so let's borrow from
this 10 so this 10 can become a 9 1 is
really taken from it and then the 6
becomes a 16 because if you think about
it this 10 was really it's really 10
tens it's in the hundreds it's in the
tens place so when you put a 10 there it
really means 10 tens so if you take one
away from it this is actually now 90 and
we have 10 to give to the 6 and 10 plus
6 is 16 so that's what we're really
doing but now we're ready to subtract so
we have 16 minus 8 is 8 9 minus 8 is 1
and 2 minus 2 is 0 so we have 18 left
over and now we can bring down this 0
right here bring down that 0 so how many
times does 36 go into 180 and now once
again this going to be s
summation it's not going to be 6 times 6
times 30 would be 180 so that would be 6
times 36 would be too big because 36 is
bigger than 30 so let's try 5 let's see
5 works so let's see 5 times 6 and
there's a little trial and error here
some times 5 times 6 is 30 put the 0
carry the 3 we don't need that that's
from last time 35 times 3 is 15 plus 3
is 18 looks like it works out you
subtract 180 from 180 you get 0 so we
have no remainder no remainder so we're
left with 36 goes into 3060 85 times so
this is equal to this is equal to 85